the next couple who is safe to dance
next week is Ivana and ko
how are you guys doing are you shocked
bummed I mean it tonight was such a good
night for us we had our best score of
the season his best dance for sure and
then the team dance was just so much fun
so obviously was a huge bummer to go
home but at the same time like I'm so
proud of the night that we had and I'm
really happy that we got to go out on a
high
the thing is I think we went out on the
high note it was a high score score
we've had the whole season and you know
it's not just about the judges scores
it's about you know people getting out
there and voting you can see that this
show can be so up and down and feel like
I want every week because it was
learning a new dance there's a great
opportunity great relationships and
family and I had so much fun what will
you miss most without dancing every week
in this ballroom you know it's so crazy
it's just like football when you when I
retired I missed the family I missed
your team provider in the locker room
now it's the same way on the dance floor
the family you know everybody we're
having fun it wasn't just about us
dancing it was about let's bring in our
own families into this whole atmosphere
and it was amazing things this assistant
how do you break this news to your kids
you know they got to watch it when they
weren't here so not good to go back and
believe me they don't forget about it
once they know that daddy's going to be
home for the long haul they'll enjoy
what do you feel like you learn most
about yourself through this process you
know courage not to ever give up on
anything especially when you're
uncomfortable doing it but there were
some times the way I wanted to give up
and I'm like you know what you just keep
pushing through in this way like a
football
just push through and everything else
turn out
what are you gonna miss most about
having him as a partner so much I mean
I'm already thinking about how tomorrow
morning we're not gonna be starting our
next week's pants like I'm just gonna
miss the work process with him because
we work really hard but we also have so
much fun and my favorite thing about
DeMarcus is he's never acted like I'm
pulling his teeth trying to get him to
do any of this he loves the work he
loves to be there and that's all I could
have asked for as a partner so I'm
really really gonna miss that what is
next for you guys what's in the pipeline
well I'm going to keep dancing I know
Lindy's gonna keep dancin straight this
is not like a one-stop shop for me and
this right here just brought my eyes
they're like you know what dancing is
fun so I feel like you know it it's
gonna be some dancing it
[Music]